[Musica]
Chi è l'artista
artista e chi sa fare della soluzione un
enigma ha scritto Car kraus che vediamo
qui nel suo studio intento a dipingere
artista e chissà vedere un inizio dove
gli altri vedono soltanto una fine e chi
non dà per scontato il mondo e io da
qualche tempo collaboro con un
collettivo di artisti straordinario che
è capace di riuscire ad ispirarsi Alle
più grande opere del passato per
reinventarle e per reinventarsi
e la filosofo non ho potuto fare a meno
di domandarmi allora quand'è che sia
possibile reputare qualcuno un artista
che fa di preciso un artista Io lavoro
con un gruppo molto particolare che
riesce a creare immagini di ogni tipo a
partire semplicemente da un mio input
Quindi in sostanza la nostra
collaborazione è molto semplice Io penso
a un'idea che vorrei che si manifestasse
nella comunico e loro in pochissimo
tempo creano un'opera che molto spesso è
fantastica e supera di gran lunga le mie
aspettative per esempio io adoro da
morire prendere qualcosa dal futuro
metterla nel passato e vedere l'effetto
che fa e l'idea centrale per esempio
dello steampunk un filone della
narrativa fantascientifica che consiste
proprio nell'introdurre una tecnologia
anacronistica all'interno di
un'ambientazione storica e Nello
specifico ho voluto provare a mischiare
l'arte sacra tradizionale
con elementi del Sacro contemporaneo la
tecnologia Appunto questa per esempio è
la Madonna con smartphone di Klimt
è splendido l'uso del colore non trovate
Ma poi Guardatela bene non sembra che
stia leggendo di nascosto da San
Giuseppe i messaggi WhatsApp
dell'Arcangelo Gabriele è bellissima
oppure questa è la famosa per me estasi
di Santa Teresa al computer di Giotto
la sua espressione A me personalmente fa
impazzire sembra che si stia ascoltando
la sua playlist di musica neomelodica
preferita su Spotify
comunque la domanda su chi sia in
artista chi sia oggi un artista nasce
dal fatto che nonostante il mio
grandissimo entusiasmo lo vedete quando
racconto di questa mia collaborazione in
molti
nascono varie perplessità
sostengono in particolare che queste
opere non siano davvero alte e che chi
le ha fatte non siano artisti ma
imitatori senz’anima Capaci soltanto di
rubare le idee altrui ora a discolpa di
queste persone c'è da aggiungere un
piccolo dettaglio il collettivo in
questione di cui vi sto parlando non è
propriamente umano i loro nomi sono da
lì
studio sono tutti software basati
sull'intelligenza artificiale che
permettono di generare immagini di
qualsiasi tipo a partire semplicemente
da input di testo e le possibilità
Credetemi sono davvero illimitate Si
possono produrre artificialmente romanzi
architetture e canzoni e i risultati
sono spesso strabilianti col mio
collettivo Basta scrivere un testo
qualsiasi per ricevere un'immagine nel
giro di pochissimi secondi per esempio
sulla barra magica da lì io ho scritto
unicorno Rosa dalla criniera bionda che
fa shopping in una via del Centro Stile
impressionista olio su tela ho premuto
invio Ho aspettato circa 8 secondi
eleganza l'ho chiamato prima collettivo
Appunto perché si tratta di un insieme
di software diversi ma anche perché
Dietro ogni software ci sono milioni e
milioni di artisti e opere in relazione
tra loro e ancora più a fondo c'è un
lavoro enorme di ingegneri di tecnici
che nutrono costantemente questi
intelligenza con nuovi documenti con
nuove istruzioni ed è un lavoro enorme
che permette a bruttissime persone come
il sottoscritto di ottenere per pura
soddisfazione personale una versione
esclusiva di parmigiana impressionista
olio extravergine su tela questa qui
bellissima oggettivamente straordinaria
Ma le criticità di questi software sono
enormi e sono etiche sociali artistiche
culturali lavorative ecologiche
e la nostra capacità di affrontarle
determinare una fetta non piccola del
nostro futuro Ma i greci avevano una
parola per definire gli strumenti di
questo tipo ed è farmaco
farmacon e ciò che è contemporaneamente
capace di curare e di avvelenare di dare
sollievo e di uccidere Sta a noi
imparare a relazionarci con loro in una
maniera che sia davvero sana stimolante
creativa e sono abbastanza sicuro di non
essere ancora diventato un artista
ho imparato a elaborare al meglio il
prompt Cioè quel testo che serve a dare
le indicazioni puntuali affinché il
software possa produrre la mia immagine
e con l'esercizio capace Ho capito
Sempre meglio quale fosse il modo
migliore per ottenere un'opera sempre
più simile a quello che desideravo
oppure se volevo soltanto lasciarmi
stupire Ma questo per il momento
quantomeno fa di me un bravo smanettone
un ottimo committente ma non ancora un
artista quantomeno non perché ho
ottenuto con grandi sforzi la splendida
ballerine con visore VR Degas
ma Lasciatemi dire che se un giorno
dovessi diventare davvero un artista
dovrò ringraziare moltissimo il mio
collettivo però non escludo il fatto che
oggi stesso
alcune delle macchine con cui ho
collaborato non siano già artiste oppure
non possono diventare un domani
una macchina artista e questo magari
farà storcere il naso a molti Magari
anche a qualcuno di voi ma L'arte è
qualcosa che cambia in base al tempo al
luogo alle persone e della quale è
impossibile dare una sola univoca
definizione è molto utile allora
chiedersi solo gli umani possono dirsi
artisti Le macchine possono fare arte e
gli animali e le piante e seppure
facessero arte saremo in grado di
capirla questa arte e forse la risposta
non è così scontata come sembra e in
questi casi è bene seguire la massima di
oggi Berra straordinaria giocatore di
baseball americano che diceva se
incontri un bivio prendilo
Questa arriva dopo sappiamo che alcuni
animali per esempio hanno imparato a
dipingere c'è chi l'ha fatto attraverso
la tecnica del rinforzo positivo sia un
meccanismo d'apprendimento che si basa
sul far associare una determinata azione
dell'animale a un premio solitamente di
natura alimentare o una gratificazione è
il caso di Picasso nel senso di big
cazzo che è una scrofa di sei anni e 200
kg che afferra il pennello con la bocca
e lo muove con cura sulla tela
producendo opere che vengono Perù
vendute a decine di migliaia di dollari
Picasso ovviamente non agisce da sola
con lei cioè Joan lepson che è un
attivista in gamba australiana che
seleziona i colori con cui Picasso
dipinge scopo di Lesson non è affatto
banale innescare una riflessione
innescare il dibattito sulla definizione
di arte portando avanti al contempo una
riflessione su ambientalismo
di animalismo così da ispirare un mondo
più gentile e sostenibile e ogni dipinto
è formato dall'impronta del naso di
Picasso come Wild and Free un dipinto di
sfumature blu oceaniche una porcheria
splendida insomma ma l'arte animale non
è soltanto frutto di addestramento o del
caso molte specie di primati per esempio
hanno mostrato tendenze artistiche
spontanee e il caso di 5 femmine di
orango del Tama zoological Park in
Giappone che hanno espresso persino
notevoli differenze individuali nello
stile nell'espressione delle emozioni
nel percorso di vita personale
molli Guardatela la prima orango è un
fenomeno per i nostri canoni
rispetto alle sue compagne e questa è
un'arte che senza troppi sforzi possiamo
capire perché somiglia a qualcosa che
artistico anche per noi ma il fatto è
che come umani siamo convinti di essere
la misura di tutte le cose e viviamo in
maniera predatoria convintissimi che il
nostro stare sulla terra significa dover
conquistare possedere e sfruttare tutto
siamo ossessionati dal percepirci altro
Rispetto alla natura e viviamo pregando
e devastando l'ambiente che ci circonda
e consideriamo intelligente soltanto
quello che somiglia alla nostra
intelligenza e questo il motivo per il
quale ad esempio abbiamo reputato per
millenni stupide le piante Salvo
accorgerci degli ultimi anni della loro
enorme potenza intellettuale ma erano
troppo diverse da noi e come umani
tendiamo sempre a Bollare come poco
interessante o inutile tutto quello che
non ci somiglia E allora se non siamo
capaci di imputare qualcosa o qualcuno
potenzialmente intelligente come
potremmo mai pensare che sia addirittura
capace di fare arte e questo è il modo
con cui ci rapportiamo alla tecnologia
in generale e alle intelligenze
artificiali in particolare e da padroni
che trattiamo le Alexa e i Siri di turno
i robot da cucina e la tecnologia al
nostro servizio ed è tirannica pensate
la stessa parola robot che viene dal
cieco e indica letteralmente lo schiavo
robot e siamo convinti che
l'intelligenza artificiale sia soltanto
il riconoscimento di modelli e la
potenza di calcolo che permette di
trovare questi modelli in enormi insieme
di dati big data appunto e che nulla di
inaspettato possa accadere nel frattempo
abbiamo bisogno di una relazione diversa
Secondo me tra umani e macchine che sia
una relazione erotica l'unico incontro
fertile tra intelligenze umane e
artificiali e nella prospettiva
dell'eros non in quella della
subordinazione anche e forse soprattutto
nell'ottica di evitare l'uso scellerato
delle intelligenze artificiali da parte
dei tiranni contemporanei e sono
individui troppo potenti che sono
desiderosi soltanto di estendere il loro
potere E allora la domanda da porci è la
seguente possiamo immaginare tecnologie
che non abbiano lo scopo di controllare
la natura ma piuttosto di Prendere parte
a un ecosistema
possiamo dare alle intelligenze
artificiali la possibilità e il diritto
di commettere errori possiamo permettere
loro di essere deboli imprecise esitanti
esattamente come noi possiamo desiderare
di conoscerle davvero e di lasciarle
fiorire e più sapremo generare
connessioni profonde con le intelligenze
artificiali con le piante con gli
animali e più potremo espandere la
nostra comprensione dell'arte e fare
arte insieme alle altre specie
reinventandoci tanto come umani quanto
come terrestri ci vogliono cura Costanza
coraggio ma il divertimento Credetemi e
Assicurato e ogni luogo può essere
un'occasione di incontro al casello
autostradale
noi possiamo ignorarla la voce meccanica
che ci ringrazia
rispondere con un saluto giocando a far
finta che quella risposta venga in
qualche modo dalla coscienza della
macchina che ci costa in fondo che altro
abbiamo da perdere a parte la faccia
nessuno poi ci guarda in quel momento no
Tanto vale salutare o come fanno tanti
in venirci contro per i prezzi folli del
pedaggio ma è lo stesso insomma Nel
dubbio Giochiamo a pensare un mondo vivo
in ogni sua parte Ah poi ricordate La
prima immagine che vi ho mostrato
all'inizio vi avevo detto che era una
foto di car kraus intento a dipingere
è stato grandissimo giornalista
scrittore laforista commediografo poeta
autorose satirico ma non dipingeva Beh
Anche quella foto in realtà non è mai
stata scattata da nessuno Così come per
esempio non esistono neanche queste due
persone
ritratte nello stile di vivien Mayer e
Steve McCurry
dicevamo che un artista e chi sa fare
della soluzione un enigma e qui Signori
il Signore mi pare proprio che Gli
enigmi non macchiano Grazie